les jeunes que je rencontre a été
extrêmement lucide et extrêmement
conscient de tout ça
extrêmement déçu aussi des quelques
rares interventions qu'ils avaient pu
avoir durant les heures d'éducation à la
vie sexuelle et affective ou là
certaines interventions en matière de
justement de prévention contre les
images pornographiques etc oui disent
eux-mêmes que ils se sentaient pas
concernés ou que c'était des discours un
peu culpabilisant du type tu t'es vu
quand t'as bu fin voilà c'était un peu
les tu t'es vu quand t'as bu du porno
c'est à dire le porno c'est pas la
réalité le porno ses passages en kevin
c'est pas bien de regarder du porno il
ne se sentait absolument pas concerné
par ça il écoute elle est en général un
petit peu
cheap au complet un petit peu blasé mais
on voit là ça en tout cas c'est un échec
ce type de discours là auprès d'eux
c'est un échec ce prêt quand on avait
monté une action médiation d amener à à
produire leurs propres contenus leurs
propres malle pédagogique finalement
autour des questions de pornographie
autour des questions de sexualité donc
finalement c'était eux qui qui crée ces
outils là ça a donné ça donnait de
chouettes résultat on a fait des courts
métrages on en avait présenté un lit
avait même conçu à l'époque la visite de
jacques toubon qui étaient venus voir le
court métrage qu'ils avaient réalisé
voilà c'était c'était plutôt un succès
cette affaire mais là je vous parle du
poignée d'élèves sur le département de
la charente évidemment que qu'il
faudrait mettre en place ce type
d'action / / ne reste sur le réseau
france mais en tout cas lorsque ce que
j'ai constaté c'est que ils avaient tous
mis en place des stratégies
d'autodéfense numérique garçons comme
filles c'est à dire ils seront en
découlent le problème en fait j'ai
vraiment pris conscience avec eux c'est
que le problème allait bien au-delà des
plates formes porno gens vers les
plateformes par nos moyens c'est mon
combat il s'est presque un combat d'hier
c'est à dire que eux ils ont accès à ces
images là pas forcément nécessairement
par les plateformes port nommés mais par
les réseaux sociaux eux-mêmes part parce
nachat par par plein de par plein
d'autres comme ça en fait par les
réseaux sociaux
et ils ont donc appris à attendre des
stratégies d'autodéfense numérique dans
le sens où nous arrive à repérer par
exemple des groupes un peu obscur des
comportements anormaux et des plus
jamais la même ils m'ont même rapporté
par exemple que sûr que quand il était
petit donc ce qu'ils appellent petit
c'est fin primaires début collège il
aller sur des sites de jeux par exemple
le genre habiller la reine des neiges et
que c'était la caper ici qu'apparaissait
les des pop up des pop-up porno ou des
liens pour aller visionner des images
pornos donc
ils m'ont rapporté ça ils m'ont rapporté
il me rapportait aussi que quand il
allait sur des sites un peu innocent
comme movistar planète qui est habillé
des poupées il était régulièrement
abordée par par des conteurs un peu
obscur qui leur posaient vraiment
beaucoup de questions etc ça a donc eu
en fait depuis qu'ils sont petits depuis
qu'ils ont croisé 8 9 ans il arrive à
opérer les prédateurs du net il arrive à
repérer les pièges où on empile leur
faire cliquer sur sur des liens qui les
emmène vers vers des sites pornos en
fait ce qui est ce qui est fou c'est que
c'est que finalement
c'est finalement vers eux qu'il faut se
tourner pour trouver des solutions parce
que ils sont confrontés de pétition anti
leader je me disais ces sites là il
existe depuis 2006 2007 depuis 15 ans
c'est une génération laisse pas loin
quoi en fait c'est ces îles sont ils
sont en seconde là maintenant où ils
sont en premières enfin ils sont au
lycée ils ont grandi ils ont grandi avec
bien même on a même qui je vois parmi
les étudiants mais étudiante qui sont
donc des jeunes adultes qui ont grandi
avec avec ça donc j'ai envie de dire le
mal il est déjà fait en fait ils ont
déjà eu accès à tous à ce qu'on peut
peut-être faire c'est essayer de faire
en sorte que que les autres générations
qui arrivent ne subissent pas les choses
mais on ne m'a déjà sept générations
cobayes sept générations cobayes elle
existe là maintenant elle rentre dans la
sexualité maintenant elle rend dans la
sexualité en ayant été biberonné au
porno en même temps elle rentre dans la
sexualité en étant conscientiser autour
des notions de consentement et c'est
parce qu'il rend dans la sexualité mais
juste après nous tous finalement ceux
qui sont au lycée maintenant ils étaient
ils étaient au collège au moment
monde octobre 2017 au collège ou à la
fin d'école d'un porte donc ils rentrent
dans la sexualité maintenant avec ces
deux visions c'est à dire d'un côté le
leader exposition images pornos et d'un
autre côté ils savent ce que c'est que
le consentement ils sont comment dire
très conscientisé autour des notions de
harcèlement des notions anglo saxon de
type slot chez ming wang li ning et star
est d'ailleurs intéressant qu'on n'est
pratiquement pas les équipements dans la
langue française tout ce qui est sport
mon prono tipul gassion ils sont
beaucoup plus au point que nous là
dessus et ils ont bien intégré il
commence à bien intégrer l'idée que la
victime c'est bien la personne qui est
filmé à son insu c'est et que la honte
doit changer de camp et que la honte
c'est plutôt du côté des harceleurs dans
tout ça il ya quelque chose qui est
vachement qui a énormément évolué sur
les questions de sexisme de raciste
d'écologie et se sont beaucoup plus
confortable ils sont tiraillés entre les
deux
[Musique]